what's popping Webheads it's me Mt and
this is a breakdown of Sam ry's first
Spider-Man film from the year 2002
featuring the first appearance of Toby
Maguire as The Spectacular Spider-Man
himself I'm going to break down all the
Easter eggs that you may have missed
after all of the times that you have
rewatched this classic of a Marvel film
so throw on your under Ros because we're
about to spider dive into it and right
before the movie even starts a piece of
cinematic history has already been made
as Spider-Man 1 would be the first ever
Marvel movie with the comic book
flipping Pages Marvel intro an intro
that would show at the start of every
Marvel film until Marvel Studios
revamped their logo for 2013's Thor the
Dark World after becoming a more
independent entity under Disney
Spider-Man 1 would also make cinematic
history by becoming the first movie in
history to make over $100 million on its
opening weekend with the movie actually
earning a whopping
$4.8 million in that weekend firmly
cementing the superhero genre as a
lucrative one after Studios were slowly
starting to have faith in them again
following the successes of both blade
and X-Men 1 and you can definitely tell
that this Spider-Man movie came 2 years
after the first X-Men film when the
movie opens with an animated credit
sequence traveling down the strings of a
spider whip in the same way that X-Men 1
had opening credits travel through
animated DNA strands and during this red
and blue opening sequence the statue
Birds on the Chrysler Building can be
seen foreshadowing Spider-Man sitting on
these Eagles to grieve the loss of Uncle
Ben later on in the film Maguire
Spider-Man would of course later reveal
that the Chrysler Building was his
favorite spot to look over all of New
York City in Spider-Man no way home and
if you consider how the designers of the
Chrysler building itself purposely put
those Eagle heads there to symbolize the
theme of Taking Flight having Peter
Parker grieve over the loss of Uncle Ben
on one of these Eagles before he takes
flight himself as Spider-Man was deeply
intentional and symbolic in my opinion
but anyways as the movie opens up with
the Midtown High School Bus we can see
actor Joe manganello as Peter Parker's
high school bully Flash Thompson in his
first ever superhero movie appearance
you know before appearing as the iconic
Deathstroke in the post-credit scene to
DC's Justice League that went absolutely
nowhere my favorite honestly put him in
Peacemaker season 2 I say it's a perfect
fit but fun fact Joe manganello didn't
actually initially audition for the role
of flash but for the role of Spider-Man
instead but manganelo quickly realized
that he was much too physically big for
the role of Spider-Man and that'd be
super awkward to see someone his size
get picked on in high school Harry
Osborne actor James Franco also
auditioned for the role of Spider-Man
but was given the role of Harry Osborne
when they saw how convincing him and
William defo played as father and son
and soon after if you look closely as
the school bus is in motion you can see
what appears to be a 26-year-old man
running after said school bus now
according to several interviews with
director Sam Ry this is actually a
17-year-old boy named Peter Parker and
not some strange man looking to groom
his way back to to the prom I honestly
don't even blame the bus driver for not
stopping for this grown ass man I'm just
kidding but Toby McGuire really was 26
years old during the filming of this
movie with Kirsten dun being a whole
seven years younger than him at the age
of 19 which is kind of weird like
Kirsten dun is the only member of that
main cast that is actually a teenager as
Joe manganello was 24 and James Franco
was 23 not sure why they didn't just
cast kids because this entire school
just looks like a bunch of super dumb
adults who've had to Pete senior year at
least five times but you know what
calculus is hard I get it but anyways
when Harry introduces Peter to his
father during their field trip we
learned that this version of Norman
Osborne was something of a nanoscientist
himself much like Tony Stark and Shu are
in the MCU Osborne's work with
nanotechnology was actually considered
some pretty breakthrough science that
impressed a bunch of scientists in that
Universe especially Otto Octavius who
seemed to very lightly hint at his
admiration at Norman Osborne's
influential work with nanotechnology in
Spider-Man no way home when he calls
Norman a brilliant scientist and tells
Peter that he outdid himself with his
nanotech suit since Octavius was
familiar with Peter's academic prowess
and Peter did write a paper about
Norman's nanotech findings in high
school Octavius likely figured that Tom
Holland Spider-Man replicated Osborne's
work when he mistook him for Toby
Maguire Spider-Man but anyways as
Peter's class is Led through the science
lab at Columbia University the tour
guide explains the origin of the spider
that would inevitably Peter Parker
apparently this lab was working on
combining the DN of three different
types of spiders to create a new
stronger breed of super spider with
those spiders being the Delana spider
which gives Spider-Man his super speed
and high jumping capabilities the funnel
web spider which gave Peter his Ultra
strong webbing and super strength and
the what the is this word and the
aalen spider responsible for Spider-Man
Spider Sense and Speedy reflexes though
the Delana spider doesn't actually exist
in real life the Delena spider does so
it would appear that someone on set may
have made a tiny super spider siiz boo
boo of a typo no big deal the good thing
is only weedos like me would notice but
anyways all three of these spiders led
to the creation of the red and blue
spider that gave Peter Parker his spider
powers which is half of the reason why
Peter decides to create his red and blue
Spider-Man suit with a later Montage
revealing that MJ's red hair and blue
eyes were also a main inspiration for
his color choices which I thought was a
very nice choice by director Sam Ry I
also really enjoy how they had Peter
wearing a red and blue shirt for this
field trip to foreshadow his coming
transformation into Spider-Man but
anyways during the following scene at OC
Corp we learn that the United States
military is deeply interested in the
development of super soldiers very much
hinting at the past influence and
existence of Captain America in this
universe despite this being a Sony
project a newspaper article that Norman
looks at later on in the film even
references the term super soldier in it
when referencing OS Corps work with
superhuman testing this newspaper
article actually reveals a lot of
important information about Norman
Osborne and his history with Oscorp
information like how Osborne graduated
from MIT at the age of 18 before
founding Oscorp around 1966 under the
name of Osborne manufacturing initially
producing Industrial Equipment before
transitioning into the defense
contracting business in the mid '70s and
to keep his company from going bankrupt
early on he had to mortgage his house
and borrow money from basically
everybody that he knew so you can see
why this dude was pretty pissed off when
the board of directors would inevitably
steal Oscorp away from him later on in
the movie it also mentions how Norman
was very much the young Super Genius
that he saw Peter Parker as as Norman's
thesis at Mat basically predicted the
miniaturization of computers long before
the concept of nanotech was even thought
possible because of this in over 250
science papers that he's published since
Norman Osborne's intelligence has become
universally respected giving Norman the
reputation
as one of the pioneers of nanotechnology
as well as one of the smartest men in
the world however this newspaper article
also goes into a lot of negative things
about Norman's personality describing
Norman as arrogant ruthlessly ambitious
having a notable lack of diplomacy and a
history of sacrificing those who have
been loyal to him which is of course
what Norman Osborne eventually does to
Dr mendle strum immediately after the
goblin serum altered his brain chemistry
the article also mentions that Norman
Osborne was married to an artist by the
name of Caroline Moulder the biological
mother of Harry Osborne in this universe
but got divorced after 10 years of a
strained and unhappy marriage a divorce
that Norman slightly references to Harry
when he insults Harry's girlfriend MJ
during the dinner scene Norman very
likely saw a lot of his ex-wife Caroline
inside of MJ as both of these women were
both artists and Norman didn't want his
disappointment of a son to willingly
repeat his own mistakes in the comics
however Harry osbor mother is actually a
Woman by the name of Emily Lyman a woman
who was was so scared of Norman osbor
that she decided to fake her own death
to make it look like Harry's birth
killed her because she knew that Harry
would have plenty of money for therapy
lots and lots of therapy we also learned
that Norman Osborne secured the favor of
a former Secretary of Defense by the
name of Michael inis the man that
General slockum refers to as his
predecessor that used to provide Norman
Osborne with his Government funding
freely before things may have had a
slight shift in American politics
however the most interesting and very
easily missed piece of information from
this article comes in the form of
casually dropping the ingredients to
Norman's secret crabby patty Goblin
formula specifically when the article
notes that in the aim of increasing the
user's strength endurance reflexes and
mental acuity OS Corp Super Soldier
program utiliz cuttingedge advances in
both chemistry and microcomputer
technology basically confirming the
presence of Nanobots swimming around the
vapors of the Green Goblin gas do you
know what this means this implies that
much like the brain of Dr Octavius was
partly hijacked by his four metal arms
in Spider-Man 2 the mind of Norman
Osborne might have been altered
accidentally by these Nanobots
amplifying the worst parts of his
personality and creating a whole new
alternate Consciousness to house these
Amplified aspects in the form of the
Green Goblin Persona like that is kind
of a major Green Goblin fact hidden in
plain sight here and I'm kind of
surprised that people don't talk about
nanotech influence on the goblin serum
more often it seems like a serum in two
parts with the chemistry altering the
physical body and giving the user
stronger muscles and the Nanobots
amplifying mental acuity but sometimes
unfortunately altering brain chemistry
the serum was of course made partly due
to the efforts of Norman's right-hand
man Dr mendal strum who in the comics
was actually the inventor of the Green
Goblin serum and after A Series of
Unfortunate Events courtesy of Norman
Osborne developed a severe hatred for
both Norman and Spider-Man that
eventually led him into becoming the
cyborg super villain robot Master after
briefly going by the name gaunt but
robot Master sounds a lot cooler what
the hell is a gaunt I don't know what
that is anyways moving on when Peter
gets home from his field trip on the
walls you can see some Revolutionary War
era art with what looks like an old
timey ship in a New England Harbor
pictured on the top and the midnight
ride of Paul River on the bottom which
is fitting considering that Paul Riv was
a man with great responsibility and
that's what Uncle Ben is all about and
right before Peter walks in we learned
that Uncle Ben is 68 years old but Uncle
Ben actor Cliff Robertson was actually
closer to 79 at the time but
unfortunately Robertson would pass away
a day after his 88th birthday on
September 10th 2011 aun May actress
Rosemary Harris however was around 75
during the filming of this movie and
recently celebrated her 96th birthday on
September 19th 2023 we love you Rosemary
please live forever and right before
Peter passes out on the floor to go
through his spider transformation you
can see the words the adventure begins
on a poster in his bedroom symbolically
pointing to Peter's own adventure
beginning like I really enjoy how they
have Peter wrap himself in a red and
blue Cocoon of a blanket to also
foreshadow the start of his body's
metamorphosis into Spider-Man and during
this transformation you can see what
looks like a tarantula flash on the
screen as well as two skeleton heads
with Peter skeleton head flashing first
and then a completely random second
skeleton head flashing on the side of
Peter for some reason but as the
transformation continues after these
Flash
you can see an animation of spiders
crawling on Peter's neurons to
illustrate his Spider Sense being
modified into his body followed by a
very X-Men movie like journey through
Peter's DNA so we can see it being
replaced by his super spider DNA much
like the TV at the genetic research
institute showed earlier and I also
really enjoyed how immediately after
Spider-Man's transformation we get the
transformation scene for the movies
villain the Green Goblin and a hilarious
moment from actor William defo who
verbally reacts to the coldness of the
clamps meant to strap Norman Osborne
into
place it's cold that line was 100% not
in the script whatsoever and was
actually Willam defo being surprised by
how cold the metal clamp was and when
Norman is being exposed to the goblin
gas in the chamber a computer screen on
the side is apparently able to document
Norman Osborne's physical transformation
data in real time possibly alluding to
the Nanobots within the serum itself
those Nanobots swimming within the also
altering chemicals of the gas seem to be
able to track Osborne's strength
potential muscle density agility visual
Acuity sensory organs reflexes synaptic
relay performance healing potential and
bone mass with the actual stickers on
Norman's body monitoring his heart rate
through an EKG what I found interesting
about the transition between the scene
and the next is that it appears to hold
Peter's very first Spider Sense
experience as Peter appears to
physically wake up as a response to his
spider sense warning him about the
violent birth of his future Archen enemy
The Green Goblin very much pointing to
those precognitive effects that the tour
guide at the spider genetic research
institute was talking about but then
shortly after we see the results of
Peter's muscular metamorphosis when he
checks out the superjack Spider-Man in
the mirror a metamorphosis that
apparently gave him a bigger penis too
which is a plus but you know since Peter
Parker has little to no game he would
unfortunately not be able to test that
new penis out until after the end of
Spider-Man 2 yeah but fun fact about
these muscles actor Toby Maguire
actually had to train 4 hours a day 6
days a week for 5 months to achieve this
muscular look for the movie as well as
to get his body into shape for all the
fighting that he'd be doing and he did
this in large part due to the fact that
initially when he was being considered
for the role the production was worried
that Maguire would not be able to
convincingly portray the strength and
fighting Spirit of Spider-Man despite
testing really well as a perfect Peter
Parker however when they saw how well
Toby did for his screen test as
Spider-Man they knew that Toby had the
dedication for both the role and the
hardcore training regiment that would
come with it but anyways when new penis
Parker is checking out MJ in her bedroom
like a creep with spider enhanced
teenage hormones you can see a picture
of Albert Einstein as well as a figurine
of a NASA rocket which showcases Peter's
admiration for science Geniuses like
Norman Osborne and Otto Octavius as well
as his interest in outer space Peter
would end up being so interested in
outer space in fact that he would
eventually end up stealing an
astronaut's fiance say in Spider-Man 2
before having an alien inserted into his
ass in Spider-Man 3 directly right up
there right up the hole but anyways as
MJ's argument with her father spills
onto the front of her house we can see
Sam ry's car parked right outside Peter
Parker's house continuing the director's
now long-standing tradition of placing
his beloved 1973 oldmobile Delta 88 in
all of his movies since 1981's the Evil
Dead starring Bruce Campbell an actor
who also appears later on in the film as
the announcer for Peter's wrestling
wrestling match against Randy Savage's
Bon saww Campbell would go on to make
further cameos in the Spider-Man sequels
as a theater Usher in Spider-Man 2 and a
French sounding waiter in Spider-Man 3
with the reason for this being tied to
director Sam raby's ambitious Spider-Man
4 plans of revealing Bruce Campbell as
famous Spider-Man villain Mysterio which
would have been super dope if Spider-Man
4 actually happened but anyway speaking
of MJ's strained relationship with her
father this is actually very comic book
accurate as Mary Jane's father Philip
Watson was extremely abusive to MJ her
sister Gail and her mother meline and I
also feel like MJ's complicated
relationship with her father in the
comics could also possibly explain why
Zen is MJ primarily goes by Michelle
Jones in the MCU as her taking the
Watson name after all the shitty things
that her father has done was likely
pretty unacceptable for Zen's MJ for a
very long time but it would seem now
these days that MCU MJ's relationship
with her father has healed a little bit
since the blitz I mean sorry to talk
about the MCU so early in this Marvel
breakdown series but I figured that
Philip Watson detail was fairly
significant but anyways moving on when
Norman wakes up after his deadly Goblin
transformation notice how his office is
filled with various masks this was an
intentional Choice by the production to
give the Norman Osborne character a
fascination with masks from different
cultures to inspire him to create his
horrifying Green Goblin mask to strike
fear in the hearts of anyone who would
dare try to fight one of O Corp super
soldiers and behind the woman who tells
Norman about Dr strom's Death is a mask
that looks a lot like Dr Doom in my
opinion however that could very well
just be coincidental but since this is a
Marvel film you never really know and in
the same vein you can also see what
appears to be a white bullseye on a beam
to the entrance of the subway as a Daily
Bugle Tru drives past Midtown eye
possibly a nod to the Daredevil villain
Bullseye and his signature white
Bullseye symbol but again this could
just be a random Bullseye that somebody
drew on the subway who knows I'm just
pointing things out that I see and after
this we see Peter eating his lunch with
two cartons of milk like a
serial killer before getting that
impressive spider moment of Peter
catching MJ's lunch after she almost
slips and falls and the reason why it's
impressive is that Toby Maguire actually
caught all of those falling lunch items
as director Sam Ry wanted to use real
items instead of CGI in order to make it
look authentic and because of this it
took Toby McGuire 156 takes in order to
make that shot happen my God that must
have been a really stressful day on set
but before we move on let's take a
moment to inspect MJ's outfit and now
I'm not trying to be the fashion police
for a teenager because you know I'm not
a creep I just want you guys to notice
the flower design on her shirt
throughout this movie both MJ and Aunt
May are fairly consistently wearing
flowers on their clothing likely to
symbolize how precious both of these
women are to Peter and how he seeks to
take care of them much like a gardener
would take care of their plants Aunt
May's house is also decorated in flower
decor for this reason as well I believe
very nice and subtle design Choice by
Sam Ry here in the Spider-Man 2 video
game we find out that his version of
Aunt May was also obsessed with flowers
as well likely inspired by the Aunt May
from the Sam Ry Spider-Man movies but
anyways after Peter sends Flash Thompson
flying we can hilariously see a poster
on the wall that says think fast which
is perfectly placed in this moment
considering that flash didn't think fast
enough in order to avoid getting beat
down by some radioactive virgin but
later on when Peter is Up on the Roof
trying to squirt his spider wrist juice
all over the fine people of New York
Peter refences DC comic superheroes
Superman and Shazam when he yells up up
in a way web and Shazam then during the
Montage that we get when Peter is trying
to nail down the design for his
Spider-Man wrestling costume we can see
that Peter was initially thinking of
becoming a black widow themed super
wrestler as the symbol for the black
widow spider can be seen on a number of
Peter school book sketches but one of my
favorite Spider Concepts that Peter
draws in his notebook has got to be this
black suit Spider-Man with these red
eyes and spider symbol costume that is
apparently also deeply inspired by the
black and red black widow spider Marvel
Comics would go on to make this
Spider-Man suit designed cannon in the
pages of Spider-Man Deadpool number
eight when a darker version of Peter
Parker makes himself a fresh new suit to
match that new attitude but then
directly after this Peter realizes that
his suit needs more color and
immediately starts thinking about both
Mary Jane's red hair and blue eyes and
the red and blue theme of the super
spider that bit him causing Peter to be
inspired to add red and blue as the core
colors of his costume and right after
this when Peter was attempting to shoot
his goo at a can of Dr Pepper we can see
that Peter has hung copies of the field
trip photographs that he took of Mary
Jane right at the top of his desk so
that he can see her every time that he
works in his room which is kind of
creepy but hey at least we know that his
heart is in the right place still creepy
though but anyways in the next scene
when Norman Osborne starts reading that
extremely informative Daily Bugle news
article the very top of the front page
has the words ENT International Playboy
Grant Curtis sued for palamon which is a
reference to one of the movies producers
Grant Curtis who is recently an
executive producer on the moonight TV
series for Marvel Studios the front page
article about OS Corp that Norman looks
at here seemingly uses the same wide
shot of Oscorp that is used early on in
the movie and after Uncle Ben drops
Peter off at the library in Sam ry's
Easter egg of a car renowned actress
Octavia Spencer can be seen signing
Peter in to his wrestling event which
was a detail that somehow missed before
my most recent viewing and speaking of
surprise famous actresses in this movie
Lucy Lawless can also be seen as a punk
rock chick being interviewed about
Spider-Man later on in the movie Lawless
is of course most famous for her role as
Zena Warrior Princess a character that
Spider-Man director Sam Ry would
reference directly in his most recent
superhero film Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness there's actually a
statue model after Zena at the
Illuminati headquarters then Peter of
course inevitably fights local wrestling
Legend Bona mcra played by real life
wrestling Legend Randy Savage but Peter
would of course quickly use his spider
powers to snap Bon saw into a slim gym
and later when Peter attempts to pick up
his winnings for the fight you can see
that the office of the scumbag Club
managers who were scamming Peter out of
his money were filled with pictures of
barely clothed women with a perfect 10
calendar even appearing in the corner of
this Frame here Perfect 10 actually used
to be a well-known adult magazine
company before the company went out of
business in 2007 I'm guessing because
one of these guys died because holy
were these guys probably their number
one subscribers but anyways after those
Club managers that just scammed Peter
get mad at Peter for not stopping a man
with a gun out of the kindness of his
own heart Uncle Ben gets turned into
swiss cheese in a surprise twist that
nobody who has read a Spider-Man comic
saw coming Uncle Ben dying what but
definitely not as big of a surprise as
everyone would get to sequels later in
Spider-Man 3 when it was revealed that
it wasn't Dennis kadine that put holes
in Benjamin but a future Sandman Flint
Marco instead in the comics however
Uncle Ben isn't actually killed on the
street but is actually killed in his own
home after Ben accidentally startles an
intruding burglar which to be fair was
quite rude of Uncle Ben I mean if you're
home alone make some noise so the home
Invaders know where you are I mean
that's just a neighborly thing to do but
anyways what I found particularly sad
about Ben's death in the movie is that
when Ben opens his eyes for the last
time you can actually see the tears that
he cried right before he lost
Consciousness like it's super sad to
think that he was just crying alone in
the street this then of course prompts
Peter to chase after Dennis the Menace
with the frosted tips transitioning from
real life actor to a fully CG Spider-Man
as he runs down this Alleyway and while
swinging after a dentist driving crazy
Peter swings past the Roger Smith hotel
at 501 Lexington Avenue before landing
on a truck for carlberg beer and later
after Peter watches the life leave
Dennis's body with uncaring eyes he goes
home and hugs his aunt and while he does
we can see that Sam Ry purposely leaves
this empty chair in frame to signify the
absence of Uncle Ben and accentuate just
how empty the house has now become
moving on the Green Goblin then of
course goes to blow up Norman Osborne's
competition Quest Aerospace who were
pitching their Badger Dollar Tree Iron
Man military exo suit for the American
government Quest Aerospace was actually
a real company that produced model
rocket kits before they were acquired by
Marvel in 1995 who had own Quest
Aerospace for 8 years before selling it
back in 2003 but anyways later when we
get a montage of Peter's first outings
at Spider-Man the first newspaper with
the headline massed man foils robbery
actually has the text within the article
repeat twice just to fill up space and
soon after this we see a newspaper with
the headline man climbs walls like
spider which features references to a
woman named Heidi fugan who was actually
one of the movies producers along with
another woman named Jessica flarity who
worked on the staff and then when we see
that man singing the Spider-Man song in
the subway you can see that his guitar
case has a spider power sticker on it
indicating that this dude was likely
taking this oneman spider show on the
road as one of spidey's top fans and
shortly after this we get a shot of
Spider-Man looking over the city with
the Twin Towers reflecting off of his
eyes as a subtle nod to the 911 tragedy
that was fresh on the minds of everyone
in 2002 then before MJ runs into Peter
on the street we can see MJ leaving her
job at the Moon dance Diner which is
actually a real Diner in Manhattan
located at 88 6 Avenue that has appeared
a number of times in pop culture with
one of the more well-known instances
being in the TV show Friends with Monica
having also been employed at the Moon
dance Diner herself who Monica is I
don't know I don't watch Friends because
I love myself I'm just kidding if you
like friends it's totally fine I'm just
being stupid then during the transition
to the next scene a flag on the side of
a building has the words the web string
platform on it which is ironic
considering that the sides of all all
the buildings of New York are the
platforms for all of Spider-Man's web
strings then when Norman and Peter
confront Harry about his secret
girlfriend Harry can be seen wearing an
Oscorp green colored shirt which I
believe was a purposeful design choice
to both represent the Green Goblin serum
as well as Harry Osborne's deep desire
for his father to notice him because all
his dad cares about is oscor and
speaking of shirts when Peter heads to
the Daily Bugle in the following scene
we can see Elizabeth Banks B Brandt
wearing flowers on her shirt just like
Aunt May and MJ tend to do I mean this
makes sense considering that in the
Spider-Man comics Betty Brandt has been
one of the special women in Peter
Parker's life with Peter's attempt at
flirtation with Betty in that scene
being a nod to their history in the
source material and later during the
unity Day Parade an ad for the Lion King
Broadway play can be seen in the wide
shot before we get a performance from
R&B singer Macy Gray singing my nutmeg
fantasy from her 2001 album the ID then
as the Green Goblin attacks the crowd we
can see Stan the Man Lee grabbing a
little girl to save her from falling
Rubble this would be Stanley's second
cameo in a Marvel movie after X-Men 1 in
the year 2000 then as Spider-Man is
swinging through the city after saving
MJ from falling at the unity Festival
they swing past a Daily Bugle newspaper
box with the headline Subway Bandits
strike again police offer token response
which is of course a subway token pun no
doubt courtesy of Jameson's bril mind
and as Peter and MJ swing through the
city MJ is actually gazing lovingly at a
lifeless Spider-Man dummy that she's
hugging in front of a green screen which
is kind of hilarious and later when
Norman goes to confront the Goblin in
front of the mirror in his office Goblin
tells Norman to follow the cold shiver
running down his spine in order to find
him which I found to be excellent
symbolic writing considering that the
goblin is literally a cold shiver
running down Norman's spine as the
goblin serum itself appears to have
implanted this new cold Consciousness
into Norman's nervous system and when a
goblin hands Norman the newspaper about
the Goblin's Unity day attack on Time
Square the paper refers to the goblin as
a weird green freak From Another World
which I found to be retroactively
amusing living in this post Spider-Man
no way home world where William def's
Green Goblin literally becomes a weird
green freak from another world and man
do I truly love every time William Defoe
has these monologues between Norman and
the Goblin because this dude is
genuinely such a great actor who can
portray two different identities so
flawlessly and one of my favorite
missable details about this scene is how
Sam Ry deliberately had the goblin
reflection have a little bit of a loose
hair on the right side of his forehead
despite Norman Osborne himself not
having that Loose Hair at all firmly
cementing the goblin as a separate
entity being projected by Norman's
fractured mind onto the mirror an entity
that refers to themselves as Norman's
greatest creation which is deeply
reflective of Norman OS born's selfish
and narcissistic nature I mean with
Harry Osborne trying so hard to get his
father to notice him having the goblin
claiming himself to be Norman's greatest
creation shows just how much Norman
values the creations of his own
Ambitions over the living biological
creation that he made like the Goblin
and Harry Osborne are both Norman
Osborne's kids fighting for his focus
and attention throughout this movie and
I love it then right before Goblin burst
through the window of James's office at
The Daily Bugle I noticed that the
suspenders that JJ wears seems to hint
at Jameson's liberal political leanings
as they are designed with political
activism signs like save Social Security
and cut tax and later on when the Daily
Bugle eventually publishes a newspaper
article about the Goblin's attack on The
Daily Bugle on the top right of the page
you can see an article about the harbor
rising and scientists considering
options also showing that Jameson has a
bit of a passion for protecting the
climate but anyways as the employees of
The Daily Bugle freak out at the
Goblin's arrival you can you can see a
daily beagle newspaper headline on the
wall that says gorby out and Boris in
which is a reference to the fall of
Mikael Gorbachev Soviet Union and the
rise of the nation of Russia under Boris
yelson and as much as Jameson is a dick
to everybody around him the way that he
actually protects Peter Parker by
refusing to give him up to the goblin
shows how good Jameson actually is on
the inside truly one of my favorite
moments from this movie then later when
the goblin has a face to face with a
weakened Spider-Man he proposes that
they both team up to do bad things
together as fellow super soldiers which
is very similar to what Deacon Frost
proposed to blade in 1998's Blade just
four years prior the goblin then warns
Peter that if they don't work together
then they'll just keep clashing over and
over again until they're both dead which
is ironically exactly what would happen
to Ultimate Spider-Man in 2011's
Ultimate Spider-Man 160 and later when
Goblin surprises Spider-Man inside of a
burning building after disguising
themselves as an old lady he asks
Spider-Man if he's in or out out in
regards to his offer to team up to which
Spider-Man replies that it is the goblin
who is in fact out which is exactly what
the board of directors told Norman
Osborne when they kicked him out of os
Corp and exactly what subsequently got
them vaporized into skeletons so having
Spider-Man say that specific phrase to
the goblin was a great call back to show
just how much Norman and the Goblin just
hate being said no to and because the
goblin was disguised as an old lady when
Peter arrives to the Thanksgiving dinner
late he jokingly tells the group that
had to beat an old lady with a stick in
order to get those cranberries which is
technically true in a way the Green
Goblin then goes to attack May Parker
After figuring out Peter Parker was
Spider-Man at dinner forcing May to
finish the Lord's Prayer from The Book
of Matthew chapter 6 in the Bible and
when may is at the hospital Mary Jane
brings her flowers which may seem like
just a regular thing for a person to do
but considering how this movie has
themed both of these women after flowers
I found this gesture to have layered
meaning here although one of the things
in this movie that never really
understood was why Harry got so upset to
see MJ holding Peter's hand at the
hospital I mean Peter's aunt just got
attacked and Peter needs emotional
support so why would Harry get so upset
over that given those circumstances like
that seems kind of lame but regardless
get upset he does which leads him to
emotionally confide in his crazy ass dad
who finally gives him the fatherly
affection that Harry has been craving in
the form of a hug causing Harry to cry
at his father's Embrace and acceptance
then when Peter talks to Aunt May when
she wakes up in the hospital we get
another reference to DC Comics as
Superman when Aunt May tells Peter that
he does too much and to slow down
because he's not Superman Peter then
goes to call Mary Jane to make sure that
she's okay but instead is greeted by the
goblin who asks if Spider-Man could come
out to play a question that the Green
Goblin would repeat to all three
Spider-Man at the Statue of Liberty and
Spider-Man no way home and later when
the goblin attacks the Roosevelt Island
Tramway check out how this dude can
carry this entire tram car with just one
arm I mean like that is freaking insane
man like the goblin is truly one scary
strong ass super soldier like godamn
then when the goblin forces Spider-Man
to choose between saving Mary Jane or
saving that tram full of people
Spider-Man of course chooses to save
both which is a Hallmark of a true
Spider-Man and why Miles Morales is
currently trying to save his father and
the entire spiderverse and Beyond the
spiderverse and this all then leads us
to the final showdown between Spider-Man
and Green Goblin a fight that is truly
Sam Ry at his absolute best giving us a
gruesome and dirty fight that literally
ends with the villain being impaled in
the freaking Balls by his own Goblin
glider a symbolic death considering just
how much Norman Osborne ignored the Sun
that those very same impaled balls
helped create the just reward for a
father who chose His science Creations
over his biological creation at Norman
Osborne's funeral Harry Osborne says
thank God for you Peter just like Norman
Osborne did to Spider-Man right before
he died which I thought was a great way
to show just how much alike both Father
and Son were and finally right before
the movie ends Peter stares at Uncle
Ben's grave a grave that mysteriously
has no birth or death year on it which I
found kind of funny but hey I get it
tombstones are expensive but that is it
for this breakdown of Spider-Man 2002
thank you guys so much for watching this
video you can follow me at Mass
entertainment on Instagram or Twitter or
wherever I am on the internet but most
importantly you can follow heavy
spoilers here on YouTube cuz we always
got some really fun stuff for you guys
all the time and you don't want to miss
anything so be sure to hit that Bell so
you get notifications every time we
upload a video but anyways you guys are
amazing and spectacular thank you guys
again for watching this video and I'll
see you guys next time goodbye